on avait reproché deux trois faits
juin 2018
dans la boutique Nike on avait
reproché à Pierre Ménès d'avoir agressé
sexuellement devant eux
ensuite en 2021 on avait reproché à
Pierre Ménez d'avoir agressé
sexuellement une hôtesse du stade au
Parc des Princes donc quand vous dites
agression sexuelle c'est quoi c'était
des
attouchements sexuel une agression
sexuelle ça veut dire parce que là elle
était spectateurs
c'est un attouchement sur une partie
intime du corps donc là c'était en 2018
et au final et au final beaucoup de
bruits pour rien la montagne a accouché
d'une souris c'est ce que je disais ici
d'ailleurs sur ce plateau et
ce maudit tribunal médiatique que j'ai
toujours condamné je condamnerai
toujours
à finalement
voler en éclat pourquoi
le jugement de la 24e chambre
correctionnelle ce matin
a rendu sa décision
est innocenté totalement sur la partie
du Parc des Princes j'ai entendu les BFM
TV le Parisien bien sûr d'autres médias
qui sont des procureurs qui n'ont pas
dit ça pardon ils n'ont pas dit qu'il
avait été innocenté non non pas du tout
on voit souvent la bouteille à moitié
plein ou vide selon le la situation dans
laquelle on se trouve et selon des
intérêts d'ailleurs mais les nœuds sont
à 100% sur la partie du Parc des Princes
sur la partie de 2018 magasin Nike il
est totalement innocenté sur une des
deux vendeuses et sur la deuxième
vendeuse
sur le fondement d'une vidéo qui a été
tenez-vous bien délibérément détruite
par le procureur de la République on se
fonde donc sur une vidéo qui a été
détruite
on reproche à permanence d'avoir touché
les mains de la vendeuse
et il reçoit aujourd'hui la peine la
plus basse qui existe dans le code pénal
deux mois de prison avec sursis
vous bien sans inscription dans le
fichier figeste le fichier des nains
et il a deux mois de prison avec sursis
donc en réalité il est innocenté même si
je considère que cette décision est il
est condamné attendez il est de santé
d'abord sur deux alors pourquoi alors
pourquoi
alors pourquoi pourquoi il a eu ces deux
voitures si c'est pour quelle qu'elle
fait non c'est des faits parce que vous
n'avez pas le droit de toucher les mains
donc je vous le dis Siri faites très
attention quand vous touchez les mains
d'une de vos chroniqueus parce que vous
pouvez avoir deux mois de prison avec
très attention à vous moi le problème
c'est surtout elle qui m'a fait mal
j'ai cumulés
moi j'ai le problème inverse de Pierre
c'est ridicule et on le sait très bien
c'est un des aveux pour le procure de la
République d'ailleurs qui on en avait
fait visiblement
pierre il a réagi pour nous à zerdit il
veut d'abord mettre en avant le fait
qu'il a été innocenté sur certaines
affaires regarde
salut à tous
Comme vous avez certainement dû la
prendre
j'ai été donc condamné ce matin deux
mois de prison avec sursis pour
agression sexuelle
j'étais poursuivi le
8 mars dernier pour trois affaires donc
aujourd'hui le résultat est tombé j'ai
donc été innocenté sur 95% des faits
qui m'était reprochés et surtout pour
moi le plus important sur cette histoire
du Parc des Princes qui était un
mensonge et honté alors on a d'autres
d'autres réactions de pierre dans un
instant donc il a été innocenté sur la
plupart des affaires juste c'est juste
sur cette affaire que d'une vidéo sur au
magasin dans un magasin donc de
sportsware où il aurait touché les mains
de d'une vendeuse pourquoi pour le pour
il voulait faire c'était une blague mais
pardon mais et donc deux mois avec
sursis et il n'est pas inscrit au
fichier ça c'est important ça
d'inscription figes
et pas d'amende j'aimerais dire aussi un
autre point Cyril pardon
sur l'autre volet notamment Canal+
Canal+ avait fait un protocole d'accord
ce qui n'a pas été licencié ce qui
prouve qu'il n'y avait aucun élément et
sur l'autre volet sur son ancien
stagiaire classement sans suite
ordonnance de non-lieu avec notamment
une expertise qui l'innocente totalement
donc pardon je suis désolé mais à un
moment donné le traitement médiatique
qui doit être équitable mais juste c'est
ce que j'ai dit d'ailleurs pardon c'est
ce que j'ai dit à BFM TV je leur ai dit
pendant des mois et des mois ils en ont
fait des lustres et au final ils n'ont
pas de traitement médical et c'est ce
que je condamne aujourd'hui dans la
situation actuelle c'est le traitement
du tribunal médiatique
parce que vous avez l'air finalement de
vous satisfaire du jugement relaxé sur
deux affaires condamnés à deux mois avec
sursis sur l'autre est-ce que vous allez
faire appel vous avez 10 jours est-ce
que vous dites on se contente de ça ou
est-ce que vous allez en appel pour
obtenir une relax total j'ai pas là vous
avez pas l'impression chargez le Verdez
ce que j'ai l'air satisfait pour moi il
est innocent pour moi il est innocent il
a été innocenté totalement de la plus
grosse affaire sur les trois Parc des
Princes tout le monde pensait qu'il
allait être condamné je voyais déjà les
titres qui étaient déjà prêt s à
l'Agence France Presse je l'ai vu
d'ailleurs hier ils étaient déjà dans
les starting blocks ils sont visibles en
déçu
pour moi les deux mois qu'ils ont avec
sursis c'est pardonnez-moi de vous le
dire c'est on essaie de contenter un peu
la meute voilà
donc pour moi il est innocenté
vous confirmez qu'il a été innocenté des
plus grosses affaires oui il a été
innocenté les plus grosses affaires
alors c'est vrai qu'il y avait eu
de la part de beaucoup de médias un
traitement très à charge c'est ça voilà
je vais pas parler d'acharnement
il faut le dire à un moment faut dire
les choses voilà qui a été de les mecs
il faut arrêter de prendre des pincettes
pour des gens qui n'en prennent pas j'ai
dit très achats
une santé descente
on a eu le jugement là donc deux mois
avec sursis et il est condamné donc
c'est toi là c'est quoi la condamnation
s'il vous plaît j'aimerais savoir
[Musique]
pourquoi pour agression sexuelle sur
cette jeune fille sur une des deux
vendeuses de Nike d'accord donc c'est ce
que nous racontait
pour l'autre et relaxer pour la faire du
parc qui était une affaire un peu
nébuleuse parce que l'hôtesse elle-même
n'avait pas porté plainte on n'avait pas
très bien su exetera mais ça aurait pu
être potentiellement la plus grosse
condamnation
madame maillet devant moi elle me disait
oui c'est incroyable maître il y a pas
de fumer son feu c'est ce qu'on veut
pas je pensais que vous allez venir me
dire après
je vais vous dire elle a pas été aussi
virulent que les autres médias Géraldine
son ami
et nous souvent la part de faits divers
sans qu'il y ait des jugements et on
parle avec émotion avec avec voilà notre
sensibilité et qu'effectivement après il
y a le temps judiciaire et je trouve que
c'est très bien de faire le distinguo et
que le temps judiciaire est beaucoup
plus long et que du coup forcément quand
on traite médiatiquement des affaires
voilà c'est c'est marqué d'ailleurs que
je ne viens pas souvent sur votre
plateau je ne viens ici que pour
commenter cette histoire première chose
deuxièmement effectivement je pense que
les affaires Pierre Ménès sont arrivées
en plein milieu d'un d'une libération de
la parole des femmes avec le
documentaire de Marie Portolano avec le
ballon Stamper avec le nitou
effectivement il s'est retrouvé aussi au
milieu de tout ça effectivement je pense
que si on sait on a été très à fleur de
peau par rapport à ça après j'aimerais
quand même que vous soyez tout à fait
honnête surtout chez les mains il s'agit
pas complètement de ça non plus il y a
eu un autre là demain et après les mains
sont allés sur une partie du corps de la
femme non pas du tout pas du tout alors
précisément
touché les mains c'est important
elle a raison qu'on aimerait bien avoir
des précisions bien sûr du coup
j'agresse sexuellement
un check de poitrine est-ce que c'est
dans ce cas de figure là il a été
innocenté pour cette partie d'accord
cette partie là parce que je peux vous
dire vous allez me dire voilà ce qui
était dit et vous allez me dire si
alors devant deux ont dénoncé donc elle
disait avoir caressé le dos jusqu'au
fait ça il en santé inné il avait collé
sa poitrine à la sienne puis désigner
ses cendres disons c'est énorme
innocenté d'accord cette dernière en
outre indiquée qu'il est passé derrière
elle en se frottant le sexe contre ses
fesses et nos sentait donc le seul truc
qui a été retenu c'est quoi c'est les
mains dans la main mais donc l'entre la
demande en fait
et pourquoi en fait c'est qu'au départ
il vient on est dans le rayon basketball
c'est vrai que c'est très bête je vous
le dis c'est très beau c'est évidemment
discours toi jamais je le ferai
lui il est venu parce qu'il avait cet
état d'esprit que tout le monde connaît
chez lui il le fait il fait un check de
la poitrine qui a été d'ailleurs qui n'a
pas été d'ailleurs même contesté par le
procureur de la République et il lui
prend les mains
le procureur de la République va se
fonder sur des vidéos
ces vidéos sont détruites
et en fait on va se reporter sur les PV
et je demande à la procureur de la
République mais madame le procure moi
vous avez une vingtaine de journées ce
qui pour vous confirmer qui était à
l'audience je vivais madame procure on
va écouter moi je suis un peu dans le
désarroi parce que ça fait un an que je
demande ses vidéos parce que ça serait
bien de qu'on puisse les visionner le
présent même c'est offusqué et le
procureur d'appui que nous annonce
quelque chose d'incroyable
pardonnez-nous on a détruit cette vidéo
mais vous pouvez vous reporter au PV
alors j'aimerais bien que les personnes
qui manifestent en ce moment par exemple
où les gilets jaunes ou d'autres qui ont
été notamment dans des gardes à vue et
sur le fondement de PV ou par exemple on
écarte par exemple des vidéos on
pourrait se fonder sur des infractions
non donc c'est quand même scandale c'est
pour ça que je dis à Gilles Verdez
potentiellement je vais certainement
faire interjeter appel au nom de mon
client parce qu'on se fonde sur une
vidéo qui a été détruite
donc c'est une acceptable j'aimerais
dire juste un point très important
je viens systématiquement sur le plateau
je peux mieux plusieurs fois c'est la
troisième oui tu es un ami défendre pour
défendre les femmes victimes de
violences et les enfants je le dis
toujours j'ai porté la robe pour cette
cause la seule la seule à faire sur
laquelle je me suis vraiment appliqué
pour une personne qui supposait être
coupable en tout cas mise en cause
c'était pierre menace effectivement ça
peut interpeller mais parce que pour moi
il a été victime de reproches qui
n'était pas fondé et en réalité je
m'aperçois que nous avons pas été formé
nous avocat et même nous citoyens en
réalité parce que nous sommes des
citoyens français autour de cette table
et nous devons avoir une réflexion très
importante sur ce que ça veut dire que
le tribunal médiatique vous savez ça tue
ce tribunal métier tue parce que Pierre
Ménès a tout perdu
puisqu'il a été blanchi à ce moment là
il faut qu'il réintègre les questions
Canal football
pour travailler à nouveau parce que
c'était sincèrement là
non mais c'est vrai c'est parce que
c'est la seule qui a aussi le courage de
dire ce que tout à votre âge bien sûr il
serait complètement euh bien sûr tu as
raison
bosser nulle part complètement raison
sur la faire de la vendeuse de la
boutique Nike
voilà il nous explique ce qui voilà
c'est lui ce qui ce qui l'a ressenti
regardez
proche donc à l'arrivée d'avoir enlacé
mes mains dans les mains du d'une
vendeuse de la boutique net il faut
savoir que deux mois avec sursis dans ce
genre d'affaires c'est la c'est la
sanction minimum on peut pas avoir moins
il n'y a pas d'inscription au fichier
des délinquants sexuels il n'y a pas
d'amende
c'est donc un jugement
[Musique]
que je peux pas dire équitable puisque
moi je suis convaincu d'avoir rien fait
et d'ailleurs la plupart du du jugement
me donne raison là-dedans
alors il revient aussi et vous l'avez
dit Géraldine sur sa situation
personnelle il aspire aujourd'hui au
calme estime avoir déjà payé très cher
ses affaires regardez
une seule chose c'est au calme dans une
semaine je quitte la région parisienne
pour aller m'installer définitivement à
La Baule
j'ai déjà payé très cher cette histoire
d'abord en perdant tous mes contrats
puis en tombant gravement malade en
avril et mai dernier avec un AVC
à la clé une amputation du pied en
[Musique]
janvier dernier alors
c'est vrai que c'est il a tout perdu
tous ses contrats tous ces contrats tout
rien il n'a aucun revenu aujourd'hui la
plus rien depuis combien de temps depuis
l'affaire Parc des Princes depuis un an
donc la pluie touche rien du tout rien
du tout Cyril d'accord Benjamin si
jamais il est blanchi totalement est-ce
qu'il y a un recours parce
qu'effectivement il a perdu tous ses
contrats il a plus de travail ce qui
pourra se retourner contre les gens qui
doivent accuser à tort vous pouvez
jamais récupérer Benjamin un problème
le recours c'est quoi vous savez il a
perdu sa mère dernièrement il a été
amputé
il a fait un AVC
quand vous êtes à ce niveau-là il a
perdu des supposés amis mais vous ça
vous savez ce que c'est dans ce milieu
[Musique]
surtout son papa aussi on aime toujours
sa famille mais donc il a plus rien vous
payez jamais récupérer ça sera quoi de
l'argent bien sûr c'est une part
d'énergie vous avez perdu beaucoup
c'était salé
mais Gilles dans l'affaire du parc
Pierre avait parlé d'un coup monté oui
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui ont voulu
faire tomber Pierre Mendes
il y a un tweet qui a été utilisé par
les fonctions de police et scandaleux
le PSG dans deux jours là derrière
c'était le premier but de Messi
le match a eu lieu vers 17 18h un tweet
dit alerte ou je sais pas quoi vers
trois heures du matin
je suis pas complotiste du tout je suis
très rationnel mais je me dis un tweet
qui est utilisé dans le fin fond du
placard ou du tiroir
ça me paraît parfois bizarre ça a été
même souligné pendant l'audience tout le
monde a ricané parce qu'il y avait
tellement tellement aussi peu d'éléments
qu'on est allé chercher dans les fin
fond du tiroirs du tiroir
la réalité c'est que tout ça était
n'importe quoi et on a monté un dossier
en épingle sur un fond de décor
médiatique et pour créer du buzz et une
usine à gaz voilà quand vous dites on
vous pensez à des gens je pense qu'il y
avait des gens qui avaient des comptes à
règles permanent effectivement c'est pas
quelqu'un qui avait sa langue dans sa
poche je pense également qu'il y avait
une certaine amertume pour certains
qu'on ait pu négocier à l'amiable avec
Canal+ beaucoup aurait été content qu'il
soit fait licencier ce qui a pas du tout
été le cas parce que je répète aucun
élément à charge dans l'affaire Canal+
il a eu une ordonnance de nos deux donc
innocenté blanchit totalement sur son
ancien stagiaire il vient d'être blanchi
à 95% sur deux affaires sur 3 et la
troisième c'est juste parce qu'il a
entre la c'est les mains pardon un
scandale d'État voilà donc si vous
voulez voilà les chiens la caravane
passe et les chiens à bois alors enfin
il Pierre Ménès si vous avez vu
exclusivité en exclusivité la réaction
de Pierre Ménès suite à son jugement
aujourd'hui
il en veut à la plupart des médias qui
n'auraient pas présenté l'effet de
manière correcte selon lui regarder
cette vidéo parce que effectivement la
manière dont
tout ça est présenté par la presse n'est
pas très correct je tiens d'ailleurs à
remercier Yahoo qui est le seul média
voire
titrer que j'étais
relaxé sur deux affaires sur trois
les autres se contentent de dire que je
suis condamné à deux mois et sursis pour
agression sexuelle moi j'avoue que deux
mois avec sursis et agressions sexuelle
dans la même phrase ça me
ça me choque un petit peu donc alors je
vous dis là moi je suis complètement
conçu non mais c'est vrai que agression
sexuelle
et sans fichier
donc c'est ça et moi ce que j'ai
condamner pour agression sexuelle si
vous n'êtes pas dans le fichier je vais
vous dire moi ce que vont lire les gens
et c'est pour ça que je voulais faire
cette émission ce soir parce que quand
il y a un problème on le dit et nous on
sait revenir sur et on sait retenir sur
peut-être des erreurs qu'on a fait moi
Géraldine le discours de Géraldine donc
il a été incroyable voilà parce que nous
on était les premières bien sûr
j'avais eu des mots plutôt heureusement
et moi j'aime l'attitude de Géraldine
sur comment on doit traiter c'est
exactement
et là elle a raison parce que je vais
vous dire moi et moi je vois tous les
types là ce matin et moi c'est ça encore
qui me rend fou avec des pseudo
journalistes des charlatons des gugusses
comme je les appelle souvent parce que
vous allez sur les réseaux tout le monde
partout Pierre Ménès condamné Pierre
Ménès qu'on avait pourquoi pour que vous
cliquiez pour que vous alliez voir
encore ce ne sont que des gens qui
veulent faire de l'argent sur le malheur
des autres et sur le buzz qui peuvent
faire autour d'une telle telle ou telle
situation c'est inadmissible et vraiment
je vous dis c'est devenu un problème
majeur en France aujourd'hui et je vous
dis je vois tous les sites Pierre Ménès
qu'on avait Pierre Ménès condamné
après dans l'article que
vous dites moi le 8 mars quand je plaide
ça pas on passe 4 heures de 9h à 13h je
vais vous dire une chose très
intéressante ce que vous dites
je sors de l'audience je pose la
question à tous les journées c'est alors
qu'est-ce que tu en as pensé qu'est-ce
que tu en as pensé tout ils me disent
franchement il y a rien il y a rien non
je me disent rien sur les titres du 8
mars
il me sortent le les réquisitions du
procure huit mois de prison avec sursis
à rien et là tu me mets écoute-moi bien
sache-le c'est toujours comme ça
incroyable alors ça tu vois cette
méthode pas du tout et je sais que tu
dis la vérité à 100%.